حب الشطرنج لم يمنعها من ممارستها حتى لو
على طاوله مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسباني في
لقطات بدات فيها اكثر ارتياحا ظهرت لاعبه
الشطرنج الايرانيه صار خادم في ضيافه رئيس
الوزراء الاسباني وهي التي اختارت المنفى
وحريتها على البقاء تحت قمع النظام في
ايران الذي لم يتاخر في الاعلان عن انكاره
لها
[موسيقى]
استاذه كبيره بلعبه الشطرنج النساء
في لقاء اخير مع صحيفه تلغراف البريطانيه
ذكرت لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه انها رفضت
امرا من السلطات في ايران طالبتها بتصوير
فيديو تعتذر فيه عن المشاركه في بطوله
العالم لشطرنج في كازاخستان دون حجاب
موضحا انها تلقت كذلك تعليمات بالقاء
اللوم على ضغوط الغرب على قرارها بعدم
تغطيه راسها
مع الحجاب لست انا ولا اشعر انني بحاله
جيده ولذا اردت ان انهي هذا الوضع ولذا
قررت عدم ارتدائه بعد الان لعبه الشطرنج
حرب بين معسكرين تتساوى قوهما هدف كل
المعسكر هو اسر ملك المعسكر الاخر بوضعه
في مركز لا يستطيع معه الهرب والهروب من
بلدها الام ومن قمع نظام الايراني
واستبداده خاصه مع النساء الايرانيات هو
ما اختارته الايرانيه لاعبه الشطرنج صارت
خادم في خطوه فسرها كثيرون بانها جاءت
دعما للاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي تشهدها
ايران منذ عده اشهر
[تصفيق]
امله ان اكون الشخص الوحيد المسؤول عما
فعلته نشعر بترحيب كبير في اسبانيا لكننا
تركنا بعضا من اهم الاشياء في الحياه في
ايران لذلك هناك مشاعر مختلطه
صار خادم تعد خامسه رياضيه محترفه في لعبه
الشطرنج تغادر ايران خلال السنوات الاخيره
ومعظمهن قررنا ذلك بعد فتره وجيزه من
مشاركتهن في منافسات دوليه من دون ارتداء
الحجاب
ملوك الشيخ العربيه